thank you so much for joining us today
we are extremely excited to be kicking
off our first corporations and Society
initiative today
my name is Louise White and I am one of
the student leaders for Cassie this year
the full coffee team includes our new
director Lisa Simpson project manager
manager Loretta Gallegos our four other
student leaders and our two faculty
directors anat Ahmadi and Paul flighter
who unfortunately are only able to join
us via Zoom today
before diving into the discussion I want
to give a brief introduction to what
Cassie is and our frame up our
discussion today and then I'll turn it
over to Jeff to kick us off
the corporations and Society initiative
engages on issues at the intersection of
markets businesses governments and
Society to promote more accountable
capitalism and governance
Cassie is known for its challenging
engagement on the issues that are often
overlooked and avoided including
conflicts of interest power and
information imbalances corruption and
the abuse of entrusted power
we aim to uncover and unpack these
narratives and their consequences
we kick off this year by diving right
into the forces that have shaped modern
capitalism and the consequences of
profits at all costs
the so-called Jack Welch effect the
legacy of the iconic CEO of General
Electric from 1981 to 2001 has been
powerful
his management style and priorities are
still a driving force in corporate
corporate culture from CEO worship to
outsized CEO packages and an unwavering
focus on shareholders and the metrics
such as accounting earnings and stock
prices that are meant to capture what
shareholders prioritize
Welch was also responsible for the
financialization of General Electric by
creating GE Capital
which arguably allowed for more
flexibility in managing earnings and
ultimately led the company to get mired
in the financial crisis
Welch and the many CEOs who have
followed in his footsteps have had an
immense impact on society
we are lucky to have David gellas here
today who together with Jeff pfeffer
will help us understand and evaluate
this impact
David gallis is a correspondent on the
climate desk at the New York Times
covering the intersection of public
policy and the private sector
he recently published a new book The Man
Who broke capitalism how Jack Welch
gutted the Heartland and crushed the
soul of corporate America and how to
undo his legacy
we have a limited number of signed
copies so make sure to grab one at the
end before you head out
David is with us today to dive into the
moral and economic consequences of a
business model that puts profits Above
All Else
previously he spent eight years as a
reporter in colonists for the Times
business section and before that served
as a reporter for the financial times
to lead and moderate our discussion
we're thrilled to have Professor Jeff
beffer akasi faculty at affiliate and
the Thomas D II professor of
organizational behavior at the GSB
ee has published extensively in the
fields of organization Theory and Human
Resource Management his current research
focuses on the effects of work
environments on human health and
well-being power and leadership in
organizations and many other interesting
topics
we could not have a better person with
us to help unpack the legacy of Jack
Welch
thank you for joining us and engaging on
the topic and we're looking forward to
keeping the conversation going with you
beyond this room Cassie has several
exciting events coming up in November so
stay tuned for some more information
look forward to seeing you there
and lastly one point of logistics um
Jeff is going to lead the conversation
for a bit but we will have time for Q a
so please be thinking about what
questions are top of mind for you
including folks on Zoom please put your
questions in the chat and we'll raise
them for you
and with that Jeff I'll turn it over to
you
so I sent unless you think I'm trying to
do something to foreign David here I
sent him these questions in advance so
that he would be primed and he responded
and said I thought a lot about all of
them and which I'm sure you have and
thank you for being here
this is a this is a remarkable book and
it's a remarkable story of a remark of a
remarkable person I want to begin our
discussion by asking you a question
about the role of the business press
this is essentially a debunking of Jack
Welch and the reputation of Jack Welch a
reputation that was of course created
by the business press I still remember
having a dinner at Talon Estonia I
believe it or not and sitting at the
dinner table with me was John Byrne John
Byrne is probably the most famous for
starting the business week business uh
business school rankings but he is was
to me interesting because he had
co-written or gross written straight
from the gotch and I sat after many
bottles of wine and said to John you are
more responsible for Jack Welch's
business reputation than Jack and he
said yes
which is I believe true
um the story of Jack Welch and his
debunking could be the story of
Elizabeth Holmes at her debunking on the
cover of every major business magazine a
business hero until John carrieu writes
Ben
and so I would love for us to begin our
discussion around the role of business
in society and around all of this by you
reflecting on and thinking about and
talking about how the business press has
contributed to
the lionizing of villains and then
they're undoing and whatever I I know
you've thought a lot about this and
you've been active in this so
talk about talk about the role of the
business press and how they often get it
wrong and how they then get it right and
how I mean in some sense you couldn't
have written this book if I follow you I
follow your predecessors hadn't uh you
know hadn't made him such a hero indeed
well uh happy to address all that and
more thank you Jeff thank you Lisa and
Louise thanks to Anna and thanks to all
the faculty and students who are here I
have to say I've done a lot of events um
for this book and this is one of those
few moments I feel like I'm like in the
Lion's Den so thank you for having me
it's really special to be here
um you're absolutely right Jeff and it's
something this issue of of my role
the business press's role and
specifically as a business reporter
someone who got his startup Forbes
Magazine someone who has written the
corner office column where I interviewed
CEOs very much you know largely on their
own terms and someone who's written
flattering profiles of innumerable CEOs
and corporations this was my own soul
searching as I went through this process
and it's been a part of my Evolution as
as a professional as a reporter over the
last many years trying to come to terms
with whose story am I trying to tell am
I trying to tell the stories of the
executives the mostly men and some women
who I cover who are enormously wealthy
and have extraordinary power to shape
not only their corporations and Society
or am I also or primarily perhaps trying
to tell the story of the people whose
lives they affect and there's no right
answer right that and it's not going to
be a binary
um
answer it's not going to be a binary
choice but in part of the writing and
research for this book I indeed had to
go on a real long journey and what I
discovered as you alluded to Jeff is
that the role of the business press in
creating the Legacy and the myth of Jack
Welch is is an essential part of the
story now it Bears noting that early in
his career right in those first couple
years it was the business press the the
popular press who who named him Neutron
Jack right and so that was Newsweek in
1983 I think and there were 60 Minutes
uh profiles early in those first 18 24
months or so when those that first wave
of factory closures hit that mass
layoffs of 150 000 people really
unprecedented layoffs of the American
working class he was named Neutron Jack
but that wasn't the end of the story
right he then started getting the GE
stock price going and we can talk about
all that in some detail but then the
business press started going along for
the ride and there was more or less 17
years after that of uninterrupted
fawning coverage to the point that it
culminated in when he retired in 2001
Fortune Magazine my friend Jeff Colvin
naming him right my friend these are all
people we all know right Jeff Colvin
naming him manager of the century this
ultimate honorific for as the greatest
CEO of all time really and that's a
legacy and a reputation that he
essentially was able to manage through I
would argue the majority if not the
entirety of his retirement right up
until uh his his death in 2020.
and so when you ask did the business
press play a role absolutely have I
played a role in lionize and CEOs I was
I got my start as a reporter covering
Facebook and Twitter and so yeah I
probably played a role
um but I think it's something that we as
reporters and and as business
Publications are constantly wrestling
with and I don't I don't pretend that
we've got it right I think on balance
there's a bit more self-awareness these
days than perhaps there was in previous
generations
I'm not 100 sure I'm not sure so it
maybe maybe before we move on to the
next question is there a thing so if you
were at the end of this you make a lot
of recommendations about fixing
capitalism
um maybe we ought to begin by saying
would you also make some recommendations
of how the business press could do a
better job of so you you use the phrase
which I think is just amazingly
excellent which is that I'm going to
tell the story not only from the point
of view of Jack Welch or the
shareholders I'm going to tell the story
of Jack from the point of view of the
communities and and the employees and
the other people that he that he
affected and that is not I think a
perspective
that is widely
adopted my senses in the business press
how do we get that perspective of a
perspective of more some people might
call it a stakeholder perspective or a
more business and Society perspective
this is from the business and Society
think how do we get that perspective
more a part of business reporting I
think it depends how we Define the
business press you know at the New York
Times I would argue that that we're
probably I mean the the CEOs who I know
would argue we're not enough focused on
telling the story from their perspective
they would argue that we're far too
concerned uh with the workers and the
communities whose lives business is
affecting every day I think the journal
it probably skews in the other direction
but but the journal has done a lot of
good reporting on this and and did a lot
of really excellent I mean Ted and um uh
I'm just blanking on both of their
authors but the the authors of Lights
Out the another book about General
Electric they did extensive reporting of
about the plight of GE workers ahead of
their book and so I think it's there if
you look I think where it's harder to
find frankly is in Publications such as
Forbes again where I got my start sir
and and specifically in Publications uh
like hbr I don't know if I'm allowed to
use that uh that phrase in these have
out grounds
um but I you know where I think it's
really missing is in the management
press I think the popular business press
is doing a better job right now and
certainly the popular press is doing a a
pretty serious job of holding tech
companies to account I would argue
certainly at the New York Times another
mainstream institutions where I don't
see the perspective shifting nearly
enough is in the management press
frankly you know and and that includes a
lot of the Publications that professors
here are publishing and and a lot of the
things that comprise the case studies
and curriculums at Business Schools
today
okay good thanks let's move on to the
second question
um
and we can come back to that of course
this doesn't come back to that
um
one of the interests one of the
interesting questions of course you're a
title the man who broke capitalism a
little bit hyperbolic uh yeah I had to
get your attention yeah that's how you
got my attention so the question I would
pose to you is to what extent is Jack
who you say gutted the Heartland and
crushed the soul
to what extent is Jack really
responsible for this or is he just a
representative of a broader movement
that you see going on and lots of things
so and this really goes to a question
that I asked academically a zillion
years ago to what extent do the CEOs
actually have as much power as we think
or are they in fact agents of you know
or just the financial markets and
broader social trends all right why why
Jack I mean if I if I had to distill the
question right and like is Jack really
responsible for a lot of this can I if I
if I could still that question
um the answer is of of course he was not
acting alone and of course he did not
act in a vacuum and of course when he
took over at this pivotal juncture in
1981 Society the economy was poised for
dramatic change right we had had a
decade of stagflation Germany and Japan
were coming online as real serious
competitive industrialized economies
Wall Street was changing the way money
was moving was changing so like
absolutely things were going to change
and and by the way there had been a
decade or more of real intellectual
um thinking and academic work trying to
reassess the role of business and
Society not only from Milton Friedman
who a decade before Jack took over in
1971 not 81 71 wrote In The New York
Times that the social responsibility of
a business is to increase its profits
right so this had been the the seeds had
been planted for real radical change but
then what happens basically nothing
until Jack takes over you had started to
see the first glimmers of some corporate
Raiders but no real movement it the top
levels of corporate America many of the
big corporations yes they were suffering
from stagflation and the stock price
wasn't moving but they were still more
or less operating from the same social
contract if you will that they had for
the last 50 years in the post-war years
right the quote-unquote Golden Age of
capitalism which which if we have time
we can talk about what that looked like
but it was a moment where big
corporations really embraced what we
would today called a stakeholder
perspective if you look at the 1953 GE
annual report they talk proudly the
first thing they tell you is how much
they pay their employees and what a
great thing that was the next thing they
tell you was how much they paid their
suppliers and what a great thing that
was because their suppliers were going
to have more money to pay their
employees and they were going to have
stronger communities and more resources
develop better products for GE to use in
its products and services and then they
say and yes we paid our taxes too and
we're proud of it and the last thing
they say in that report and that opening
statement is oh and by the way our
investors made a reasonable return
all of that changes all of that I mean
that's unrecognizable today right that
sounds like a foreign world but then
Jack comes and he flips all of that on
its head
and the way he does it we can talk about
but but was it Jack and how much did he
matter well it's hard for us to sit here
and understand how influential GE really
was in 1981 but this was a company that
not only represented at its peak you
know roughly one percent of GDP
but for a century practically had been
the corporation that other corporations
other CEOs look to for guidance it was
not only the most influential company
when it came to organizational
management design how to develop recruit
retain people how to organize a large
multinational conglomerate but also the
place that had produced more CEOs than
anywhere else this is known as sort of
the West Point for business it's where
the best leaders came from so when Jack
comes in here and starts making the
changes that we can talk about in some
more detail yet the impact of doing it
at GE was more profound I argue than it
could have been at any other company and
the fact that he didn't do it for three
years or six years but for 20 years and
and took much to his credit a company
that was valued at 14 billion dollars
when he took over and in got it to 600
billion dollars making it the most
valuable corporation in the world and
keeping it that way for about a decade
that record and going out as manager of
the century according to Jeff Colvin
essentially enshrined in the public
imagination and in the business World
his way of doing business as the best
way of doing business and we're still
living with that Legacy today
okay and
um you've I will follow up the question
with a
so there is of course as you would know
Michael Jensen who was along with Milton
Friedman a big one about you know the
maximizing shareholder return I like all
my Michaels there's Michael Milken uh
from Drexel Burnham who of course uh led
the uh you know the the Hostile takeover
and the the debt financing thing there's
Michael Douglas who said greed is good
that's Michael Douglas who said great is
good absolutely
um
so as you think about all the corporate
Raiders and you mentioned them that's
why I wanted to talk about this you talk
about the corporate graders
um and the who played a very big role
you talk about the role of
deconglomerate conglomerization
um and now of course GE is basically
going back to what it was uh prior to
um prior to Welch but you've um
you know you really emphasize Welch over
any of the Raiders t-boon Pickens or
call icon or a lot of people who've LED
very interesting and important takeovers
and you still maintain that it's him he
wasn't just responding to Trends or
forces that he had no control over you
know their old thing Flip Wilson the old
African-American comedian who you know
we just used to say the devil made me do
it Jack could say the financial markets
maybe do this I really didn't have a
choice if I did not do what you I think
nicely point out he did do for all and
with all the negative effects of that
somebody would have come along and tried
to take me over or break me up just like
they did TWA or some of these Gulf and
Western Industries or some of these
other companies so how do you what would
you respond if he if he were here which
of course he can't be and said you know
I I really had no choice this is how the
world of financial markets in the US
worked at that time yeah I mean it like
nonsense he was the CEO of GE he
absolutely had a choice and and people
didn't come knocking at his door because
he he actually you know did what
corporate Raiders did internally so like
would he have faced some shareholder
pressure perhaps but GE
even under uh reg Jones the previous CEO
was making a billion dollar profit a
year and and part of what we need to
talk about here is is is just the degree
to which
he pursued prophets at all costs and I
think there's a phrase someone used
earlier it wasn't that there wasn't any
money for workers it wasn't that there
was uh insufficient funds to keep those
factories open you know he was firing
workers and mass in the best of times
and that was that is so fundamentally at
the core of this sort of shift in the
social contract the relationship between
the employer and the employees that he
above all changed as CEO and that's a
that's a dynamic that outside forces
that outside investors
corporate Raiders for example simply
don't have the ability to do
okay
some people will argue of course that
corporate is one of the ways in which
they make their money is they liquidate
contracts you know that that they lay
people off this is implicit idea that
you make more money as you um as you
build more seniority so you're underpaid
when you're young and you're overpaid
when you're old which means of course of
all the ways in which I can make money
is not overpaying you when you're home
by getting by getting rid of you all
right the fourth question and then we'll
turn this over to the audience
um in the context of an Arts efforts to
discuss business impacts on society what
might be feasibly done I mean you talk
nicely about and I wrote a book called
dying for a paycheck about how uh how
companies and their work systems are
actually affecting human health uh
health care costs for those of you who
don't know ninety percent of the US's
3.3 trillion dollar Health Care spend is
for chronic disease chronic disease
comes importantly from stress and the
behaviors the stress causes such as
smoking and drinking and overeating so
we are there's a worldwide Financial
Health Care crisis so we we are facing
big big trouble from all of this and a
lot of costs what could be done in given
today's political climate of
deregulation
and until recently a little enforcement
of antitrust laws to really close more
closely align business and social
interests this is basically a book that
talks about the this juncture or a man
who created a disjuncture between
business and Society is that a fair way
of yeah I think yeah it's a reasonable
way of summarizing a part of the theme
what can be done to put that back
together yeah I mean to State the
obvious it's not one thing and stepping
back just a bit
um the story I tell in here is is almost
an 80-year story right it sort of picks
up at the end of World War II and takes
us to the present day
um
that's a multi-generational project and
and what I describe in here from again
the sort of intellectual underpinnings
of what became the Welsh Revolution to
Welch's 20 years in power to the last 20
years of his predecessors and proteges
continuing to sort of use his Playbook
at companies around the country this is
a multi-generational project that took
decades and decades to unfold and so
when I think about trying to undo some
of his legacy I I am in under no
illusions that it's going to be a quick
fix I think it's similarly going to be a
generational project it's going to take
decades and decades and I argue that
maybe we're sort of at that moment where
the pendulum is sort of deciding whether
it's going to start to swing back with
all the talk about stakeholder
capitalism so
what can be done well I think the
dialogue around stakeholder capitalism
um you know uh feeble as it sometimes is
is an important first step right I see
that as in a way sort of the uh
equivalent of Milton Friedman uh and his
1971 uh essay in the New York Times
magazine we're starting to have the
conversation about how things could be
done differently what needs to change
though uh listen that that includes
markets that includes regulation that
includes I mean frankly like how CEOs
and Executives think about taking care
of their people it includes labor unions
it includes employee activists and we
can talk about in detail any number of
those things but the point I try to make
is it it takes all of these things
starting to move in a different
direction and none of that happens very
quickly I highlight in the book some
examples of corporations that have
actually taken steps that I think are
starting
to undo some of the legacy of Welch and
they're pretty basic right it there are
things like making sure that even if
your employees are are making minimum
wage or even making what appears to be a
competitive rate in that market that
they can actually make enough to take
care of their families which is which is
not always the case in this country
right like the minimum wage in this
country is 7.25 cents an hour at the
federal level if the minimum wage had
kept pace with inflation since Jack
Welch took over it would be more than
thirty dollars an hour
and so when people you know I just read
an article we had in the paper today
that talked about UPS workers in Reno
who had been making 16 an hour and then
got a temporary adjustment to 19 an hour
but then it went back down to 16 an hour
yeah that's ups and I don't I and I
didn't do the work of trying to figure
out the math about how much UPS is
distributed in profits to its
shareholders of the last many years but
I bet UPS shareholders done pretty well
probably pretty good TSR there over the
last many years but like how are the
tens of thousands of people who work for
UPS in all these communities across the
country doing like not so well if
they're making 16 an hour and so that
becomes a question for Carol right like
let's go talk with the CEOs and the
executives at UPS and ask them and this
is one thing I actually try to do in my
reporting that I've done it in corner
office I try to ask like is it okay are
you okay with the fact I asked the Sam's
Club CEO
right that that your folks in the
warehouses are making 14 an hour does
that feel right to you and these are
tough questions but they're the
questions I really invite Executives and
directors to be having because when we
start like going beyond the beautiful
campus that we're on and Beyond the nice
bubbles probably everyone in this room
exists on and and walking around like
strip malls in Tacoma Washington
it's pretty ugly out there and I argue
that this is a part of how we got there
okay
do we have questions for the students
feel comfortable
stand when you ask
you hanging off your mask that would be
great otherwise no worries
um and then anyone on Zoom please feel
free to put it put it in the chat
yeah hi and maybe just introduce
yourself and let me know if you're a
student what year that'd be great
all right do you want me to call them
people yeah I saw you first so let's
have it
hi my name is Alberto I'm an MBA one
from Spain my question is around the
role that businesses should play in this
broader topic of stakeholder capitalism
versus the role that government should
look like is it really up to CEOs and
companies to be making sure that their
employees uh are earning a decent wage
or is that really the role of government
because the role of companies at the end
of the day under our current system is
to maximize return to shareholders this
is this is the heart of the issue right
and there's it's not either or and that
that's there's no easy answers there's
like if there was one perfect law that
could be written I'm sure you would have
politicians trying to write that one
perfect law so I think everyone has a
responsibility I mean I think we like
have and I don't want to get to woo here
but like we as people have a
responsibility and and I especially
invite you know future Business Leaders
to think hard about their responsibility
so does do corporations have it yes but
I is a minimum wage law really all that
it's going to take of course not
um so our what are what are some of the
other regulations that could be put in
place well listen I I think it's obscene
frankly that CEOs can make 1 000 times
their medium uh the the salary of their
median employee which is not uncommon at
a lot of companies these days the
average of those top 500 companies uh
the pay ratio as many of you hopefully
know is 300 something to one compared to
the median employee so like is there the
potential for regulation there it'd be
highly unpopular but sure there's the
potential for regulation
um Anna and I who unfortunately couldn't
be with us here today we're just having
an argument on Zoom before I came up
here
some people in this room can properly
relate uh
and she was uh she was making you know
we were getting into it about share
BuyBacks and dividends and and I listen
I'm not anti-buybacks I'm not
anti-dividends I'm not anti-profits
um and she was making a strong case that
simply taxing those is of course the
Biden Administration has now begun to do
as part of the IRA past this summer
um that that that's irrelevant right
that's not gonna that that that's not
going to change anything and I said
listen maybe so but I call for uh
attacks uh on BuyBacks and dividends in
the book and my intention there my hope
my thinking was that at the very least
it would potentially dissuade companies
from just reflexively trying to return
cash to shareholders and think about how
else they could find Productive uses for
that because the store you know one of
the stories in this book is the fact
that Jack Welch not only returned tons
of cash to shareholders which is like
maybe great but it's what he didn't do
with that cash and what he didn't do was
like invest in r d what he didn't do was
invest in real capex what he didn't do
was pay his employees really well or
over over the many years and what that
left was a company that Jeff emel who I
know I couldn't find his office I tried
to go leave him a note but I couldn't
find it
um it's a company that Jeff Emma when he
took over in 2001 as he told me as part
of my reporting for the book was in like
way worse shape than he expected when he
started to pull back the hood and
understand what he had inherited he's
like wait these businesses have been
starved for Capital
these come you know my divisions I've
not had like the r d that they needed to
have years worth of of backlog of like
great products in the hopper that can
then keep dominating the competition
what he found was that all these Decades
of just relentlessly returning cash to
shareholders above all else had
fundamentally left GE in a much weaker
position than he expected so again I'm
sort of going off on a rant here but I
get exercised about these things
um it it's not one thing right and like
it's it it has to be this Matrix of
Corporations yeah taking some
responsibility for it governments
finding the appropriate regulations
which I get totally agree is exceedingly
difficult in this moment
um but I also think it's it's a total
cop-out frankly to say like oh
corporations you know we just play by
the rules and these are the rules so
we're just going to do it and you know
if you want to change the rules well
Washington we look to you I just think
that's fundamentally irresponsible as as
a person and as as a business leader
yeah I tell you
much Fabiano
and I wanted to kind of hear your
thoughts on how much of that part of the
problem is the homogeneity of these
groups that sometimes are very
disconnected or not really familiar to
what might be you know the the concerns
or the pain points of people that are
actually getting minimum wage and how
can we attack the problem from that
aspect of just getting more maybe
diversity
um on the people that we're expecting to
take leadership
um but that don't aren't necessarily
incentivized to do so yeah okay and just
to clarify when you say these groups do
you mean Executives yeah
Executives directors the the leaders of
corporate America absolutely
um I I think you raise an incredibly
astute point which is one I sort of
alluded to here which is that most
people who have senior roles in
Corporate America just like most people
in this room like live in a really
comfortable bubble
um and are pretty disconnected from
those concerns and uh listen I'm all for
more diversity at the executive level
and at the director level and one of the
things I call for in in the book is
worker representation on boards right
like uh that's a given in Germany it's
happened here in the United States
before but again it's like a completely
foreign concept no one even tries it
these days
um but I think again bringing that
worker perspective into the boardroom is
is absolutely a worthwhile effort
um you know and when CEOs actually try
to ask that question that you asked
things tend to change pretty quickly one
of the stories I tell in the book is
about Dan Shulman the CEO of PayPal
and Dan for whatever reason right and
and I always love talking to CEOs who
ask this question but he asked this what
I think is like one of the best
questions an executive can ask
themselves
which is what is the life like
for the person in my organization who
makes the least amount of money
really sit with that question right
really and what he did he asked his team
and I know the team that did this you
know Dan asked that question several
years ago he said tell me what it's like
to work at PayPal but make the absolute
least amount of money of anyone in this
company and so they went out and did the
research and he figured listen PayPal is
a I don't know what it is a 100 billion
dollar market cap company throws off I
don't know 8 or 20 in Prophecy I mean
Gonzo tech company it's got to be good
right
and the results were really ugly because
guess what PayPal employs call center
workers who work in the suburbs of
Phoenix
and what were their lives like well not
so good yeah right they were choosing
they were choosing between textbooks and
Christmas presents they were choosing
between gas money and health care
and Dan was not comfortable with that
answer and so much to Dan's credit and
Dan's not perfect and PayPal's not
perfect but much to Dan's Credit in this
case he said we got to do something and
and even more to his credit he
understood that just giving him like a
30 raise from from 16 an hour to 19 an
hour was not going to solve the problem
so what did he do they developed this
financial Wellness initiative they
worked with academics and what they did
first they figured out they came up with
a new metric right you can't change what
you can't measure so they came up with a
new metric called
um what is it the uh uh ndi net
disposable income how much money do
their employees have at the end of the
day after they took care of all their
basic needs how much money they actually
have to then figure out what they want
to do with life how do they want to use
to improve their lives in the ways that
are most meaningful to them after
they've paid rent and bought their
groceries and paid their health care and
and most employees at that lowest level
had like almost no net disposable income
and so we said okay that's the Benchmark
we got to measure against it and we got
to fix it we've got to get that way up
and so they came up with four things to
actually do that number one people got
big raises at that lowest level and
guess what that took money but it didn't
take that much money because you're not
paying them that much you you give them
a 30 raise guess what like that doesn't
that that's barely material at a company
the size of PayPal so people got big
raises at the lowest level next he said
we're going to give you
um rsus or in some case stock grants
depending on your seniority everyone's a
shareholder now everyone's a shareholder
ever you know our you're all going to
rise our if the Tide Rises you're all
coming with us brilliant you know how
many workers at Big corporations in
America these days actually are
shareholders an infinitesimal small part
that's another you know great again I'm
not pretending you can regulate that but
that's an easy thing to do
um next we're going to give you a
financial literacy program he understood
and they discovered in their research
like at that level you know real front
line workers really uh lacking for basic
financial literacy how to save how to
invest all these Basics that again we
may take for granted uh it is really
quite foreign territory to many many
Americans especially on the front lines
of major companies and then the last
thing he did he understood and come came
back in the data the biggest stressor
Jeff the biggest source of financial
hardship
was Healthcare of course
because Stanford University healthcare
is trying to extract as much money in
from Society of course absolutely and so
what did he do he slashed health care
costs he said we're just gonna eat it
PayPal Inc is going to eat a huge large
I forget the exact number it was 40 or
60 percent more of upfront Healthcare
out-of-pocket health care costs we're
just going to eat it as a company and
guess what happened right like net
disposable income this invented
Financial metric I went through the roof
everyone suddenly had the money that
they needed to do like have groceries
and textbooks to have gas money and
health care all of a sudden retention
went way up all of a sudden they didn't
have as much turnover and guess what
that was a huge cost so now like the
money that they're spending on their
people is money they're not spending on
Recruitment and and training and then
guess what happened like uh net promoter
scores through the roof people love
talking to PayPal service workers
outside Phoenix now because they were
happy they loved their company now and
they could do a better job representing
them now does all of that necessarily
like translate to PayPal having a better
quarter like maybe not in the immediate
but is Paypal a fundamentally like
healthier more cohesive happier company
at a pretty low expense
yeah absolutely and so uh I this all you
know is just a rant from your astute
question about like how do we get uh I'm
I just rant now
um uh about how do we get those kind of
perspectives uh into the boardroom into
the c-suite yeah we need those there but
but I also don't I think it's a cop-out
to pretend like until we have perfect
representation people can't make good
decisions right it what it takes is CEOs
Executives directors actually just
trying to empathize with their most
vulnerable employees
so when you're talking the word that
came to my mind is stewardship
that that there are some people who are
good stores of the physical environment
in terms of how they manage their
company and there are some people who
are good stewards of the human
environment who may who manage their
their companies
and as you and I discussed uh prior to
starting this session unfortunately the
door School of sustainability has under
emphasized human sustainability as
opposed to all the technical aspects of
sustainability but there's some there's
some people are good stewards you
described in PayPal is someone who took
the idea of stewardship seriously that
where that just as you you would need to
be good sort of the physical resources
every day people come to work in your
organization and when they come to work
they have entrusted their psychological
and physical well-being to you and some
people take good care of it and some
people don't and pay people does does
and Jack didn't care
so it's interesting
yeah please Louise I have a question
from Zoom from Catherine he's gonna ask
for her Catherine says 401K for
synthesizing as American workers to put
their retirement savings at risk in the
stock market does this fuel outside
growth in markets and drive the
insatiable pool toward greater investor
Returns what are the alternatives to
ensure secure retirements for
hard-working employees can you say it's
more slowly and I also I don't and I I'm
I'm not a 401K expert so I don't know
I'm also just going to note we have like
there's a meeting it's is this it's okay
I just want to make sure we didn't lose
haven't lost our Zoom audience we'll get
enough flashing message up here all
right one more time
does that Trend fuel
fuel size growth in markets and drive
that insatiable pool toward greater
investor returns all right again this is
like an important part of the Matrix
um and so the does the for just breaking
it down like yes I I know this all too
well as someone who has a 401k that's
gotten hammered over the last uh few
months yes it doesn't feel great uh yes
we are putting our savings at risk but
on the other hand like people are going
to have assets and they're going to be
they need to be invested
um I have not frankly given a lot of
thought and I try to be real clear where
like I'm beyond my event horizon of the
things I think about
um about the degree to which
um these enormous uh pools of capital
which we're sort of in this
unprecedented era
um uh are affecting outsized risk-taking
in in markets and Investments so that
like that that's a conversation I'm I'm
not prepared to have in an intelligent
way I'd love to learn about it I think
what to me that's almost the symptom of
some of the the problems we've been
talking about it's like with the fact
that there are these enormous pools of
capital floating around in a way to me
um because some of those are 401K
Investments yes
but a lot of them are private pools of
capital and those are probable as a
capital now someone's someone's nodding
um uh
to me this is a reflection of like what
else
where else could those profits have gone
over the years and I'm thinking here
about the the capex and the r d and and
and and the the pay and the benefits
that could have been going to workers
um so yeah I I don't want to go much
further because we're sort of out of my
expertise here but
um yeah please
uh my name is Willie Thompson I'm from
Georgia I'm an MBA one and
I know you started talking about the
framing earlier around how
um
you know
uh you know he was sort of like the
Crown Prince of capitalism in a way and
I'm wondering without being too
polyamished about where we are right now
it's way two percent into the 21st
century but are there any people you
think that are sort of stewarding in a
way to use the term like their companies
in such a way that they've become sort
of
I guess shiny examples of sort of how to
correct some of the ties you talked
about earlier like the anti-welch
um it's so hard to come by and and
I I resist offering up sort of a
singular example because for some of the
reasons I said earlier Welch had so much
influence across so many different parts
of business and Society GE was so
influential its history as sort of a a
source of other leaders was so
influential its ability to set the
agenda for Corporate America was so
important and I just don't think we have
a company frankly that that comes quite
as close today I mean you could argue
that Amazon perhaps or Netflix with some
of its culture but but we're sort of
grasping here the one person I think
that has really distinguished themselves
as a singular
um uh uh CEO and founder who's doing
things differently is is someone I had
the opportunity to write the story about
just last month I wrote the story I
broke the story about Patagonia founder
Yvonne chinard giving away his company
lots of nods in the audience now much
smaller much smaller company much
different set of uh of concerns going on
and yet the way that company has
operated admittedly on an infinitesimal
smaller scale
is is in real direct opposition to just
about everything I write in this book
and of course he came up with this
creative way to sort of think about his
legacy and and and how he wants to use
the equity of that company essentially
um but if you look beyond the headline
from last month and actually interrogate
that company's decisions
um around things like paying a premium
for organic cotton starting in the 1980s
about offering on-site at child care and
maternity leave starting in the 1970s
this company has done things differently
every single step of the way and guess
what they still have a 13 plus profit
margin every single year which which
again to me sort of exposes the lie that
people think it's binary right we either
have to maximize profits for our
investors full stop and that has to come
at the expense of everyone else
um or Were Somehow like uh pollyanish
like hippie company who doesn't make any
money and just like sits a you know in
the cafeteria eating organic food all
day it's not either or
and it's interesting because I
interviewed Patagonia because when I
turned into my manuscript for dying for
a paycheck my uh editor at the time
Hollis heimbach said you need some
positive examples this book is too damn
depressing and and I interviewed
actually the head of HR for Patagonia is
a wonderful guy and he you know he said
we hold ourselves accountable uh you
talk about the onside daycare he said we
measure the percentage of women who have
children who return to work at Patagonia
and and and and we hold ourselves
accountable with and that and I said
what is your goal he said our goal was
that that that that we will provide an
ability for women who once they they get
married they were they're married when
they come they have children and they
have the opportunity to actually have
something which is almost impossible in
the United States a career and a job and
and any life and they can see their
children not on a damn screensaver and
he so he held himself accountable for a
lot of measures that are quite quite
interesting with respect to that so
Patagonia is an exceptional organization
yeah
and and to just to like put a put a
explanation point in their their
profitable of course right like they
make they are a for-profit corporation
that takes making a return every single
year real seriously yeah please
uh my name is Cooper I'm a second year
MBA student I'm right here in the Bay
Area I'm a huge Oakland A's fan so I
love Moneyball and one thing that stuck
with me with Moneyball is there's a
piece where they talk about how everyone
in the major leagues was doing Advanced
analytics to see what players were
undervalued for a while only the A's
chose to act on it and I kind of think
about some of this corporations and
Society stuff in a similar way where
like you have the counter examples of
Patagonia you have
companies paying a lot of lip service to
CSR and saying we're going to do this
we're going to treat employees right or
at least the idea is in their head but I
don't see meaningful action on it so I'm
curious from what you've seen talking to
CEOs researching these companies like
what is the real Tipping Point or driver
of taking that theory and translating it
into meaningful executive action yeah
this is this is the question and I don't
have the perfect answer I mean I don't
pretend to because it's uh
I I don't want to repeat myself but like
it it's just not one thing and it's and
I don't also want to overstate how
optimistic I am right the incentive
systems that are entrenched in our
society are so powerful and I would
actually argue they're they're more
powerful than the ones that were sort of
keeping the guardrails on the Golden Age
of capitalism right there there was an
opportunity for uh Executives and uh
investors and corporators and Regulators
who sort of deregulated
um a lot of the American economy uh and
you know I also there's a political
narrative in this book about essentially
Reaganomics and what members of the
Reagan Administration did
um to to to essentially unleash a lot of
the activity we're talking about and
make it permissible make it legal
BuyBacks and you know BuyBacks were
illegal and for for 50 years right and
now we just assume that they were
illegal because if they were considered
to be
companies manipulating their own stock
and now we just accept it as if it's
it's like the weather but it's not these
are choices that we as a society make
these are choices that legislators make
um and so what does it take what's that
Tipping Point I don't know right and I I
don't know that there is a big societal
Tipping Point that's going to get
everyone moving in the right other
direction really quickly which is why
again like I my editor also the the
reason there's a how to undo his legacy
is because my editor I turned in the
manuscript without the final chapter and
my editor said we have one more chapter
because we have to give people a hope it
was like I don't know how much hope I
really have
uh these damn editors I know so but it's
uh so I don't know you know I don't know
I think it's it's a lot of little things
and maybe we make some progress and
maybe life is like less shitty for some
people that's my hope
but I would I would say in response to
your question that the um you know when
the Business Roundtable came out with
their statement about you know so social
responsibility all this other stuff I
mean you could tell us
immediately because they have not
changed how they pay people if I'm if
I'm going to pay you based upon stock
price the idea that you would be
interested in stock price does not take
Advanced degrees in Psychology to figure
out right you know I mean the reason why
people are interested in stock prices
because over the years their pay is
increasing and their wealth is
increasingly tied to the price of their
shares yep so so of course they are
interested interested in maximizing
stock price holding aside the pressures
of the financial markets if if they
don't do that yeah so until we change
what people are paid for you know
nothing nothing that's going to change
I've been ever since I did dying for a
paycheck on a um quest to find the
district's attorney who arrests the CEO
for murder
because the connection between work
conditions and and and mortality and
morbidity are in many instances
depending upon the work conditions
almost as high as the connection between
smoking and cancer and we've done almost
nothing about it so it's it's it's yes
we have we have a long way to go we're
running closer time but we have most of
the time we have more questions
yeah I saw you and then we'll try to get
to you hi I'm Sebastian from the msx23
um my question was about you talk about
a lot of indicators that might
make a sense of progress and I was
thinking profit is a very strong
indicator that everybody watches and
it's very common and easy to follow so
do you think there is a indicator a
macro indicator that each CEO or C suit
executive should anchor in order to see
what their policies are doing making
progress and see how you achieve this
progress and continue moving forward and
saying hey we've we have done something
yeah that's a great question I mean
that's a question for like I I that's
like what you guys should be doing
honestly brilliant it's like that's a
tremendous project
find those indicators there are groups
out there like just Capital that are
trying to do some work in this Arena
trying to answer those it's not my work
um but but yeah that's exactly the right
question and then Peg CEO compensation
to those metrics like I said it earlier
we can't change what we don't measure so
let's find the right things to measure
and I mean off the cuff right like I
think net disposable income I don't know
if that's the perfect measure but I
think what Dan and the team at PayPal
are doing which I know other people are
now trying to do there is movement afoot
right I think people are this
conversation is happening uh in
boardrooms around the country it's not
just PayPal it's not just Unilever right
like there I think there's a growing
recognition that many CEOs want to be a
part of this so they're looking for
those metrics but I would go further
down I mean I would go to like test
scores at Public Schools I would go to
homelessness rates
um I think I I think to the point you
know know to to the very place we are
with the corporations and Society
Institute it go it's there's got to be
an acknowledgment
among CEOs that their decisions that the
actions of a corporation Ripple
profoundly beyond the the walls of their
offices and factories and affect every
facet of society we may have time for
one more please
I'm Libby I'm an MBA one from Madison
Wisconsin
um I was curious you met you mentioned
earlier
um that you know at the same time Jack
Welch's CEO um you know private Equity
takes off investors take off and I was
wondering if you could complicate the
story a little bit with you know what
investors are doing at the same time and
if that you know
there's a change you'd make in that
Arena to address this as well yeah I
mean it absolutely right like was did
the rise of PE
play a role uh alongside all this yes
absolutely I still you know I I chose my
villain and I'm sticking with him
good point
and I think this is maybe like a
potentially an okay way to end which is
like I think PE has gone completely off
the rails and and indeed you know every
GE executive who was like a jack Walt
Protege who didn't go run his or her
mostly his own company as a CEO went
into PE uh all these guys did
um and and if you look at the way PE
operates you can make the argument that
like it's the Jack launch model many of
these guys tell me that right you've
talked to guys at private Equity firms
in New York and I cover I mean I covered
private equity for the times in the Ft
for many years and they're like we're
just doing the GE Playbook
um over and over and over but the last
thing I'll say is like even at some PE
firms there are efforts to change it
there there are a couple portfolio
managers and a couple men and women at
some of the firms that have started
asking the same question that Dan
Shulman asked and they've started
looking for way days to make sure that
the workers at those companies
actually benefit when that portfolio
company changes hands and there was an
example that my friend Leslie picker at
CNBC wrote about you not in your head
there's this garage door opening company
in the middle of the country that you
know went through a turnaround
went private
went out again
and they gave stock to the employees and
all of a sudden there are a bunch of new
millionaires in maybe it was even
Wisconsin I forgot where it was it
wasn't Wisconsin right but like all of a
sudden these workers who had put in
their time who suddenly felt like they
were creating wealth not just for like
some Executives on Park Avenue but for
their own communities and so we look for
those examples what is it going to take
to undo this it's like it's that it's
the new metrics it's all these little
things together over many many years
and with that we I think out of time
thank you